In terms of the,
the skill of executing stories,
I would say we're getting better.
That's,
that's one thing.
Okay.
I think clearly when I,
for example,
I mentioned the series damages and in
fact that was just an article in the New
York magazine the other day about
damages and they brilliant way in which
that that series does something,
um,
that really never been explored quite
that way before.
They use flash forwards as hooks.
They give you glimpses of the future,
but only glimpses.
And so that they put you in a state of
semi dramatic irony.
You know,
more than the character knows the
character is going to die.
Okay?
You know that this character is going to
die.
Then you go,
you flash forward to their death,
all right?
And now you're watching,
you go back and you're watching them in
the present.
So you know what?
He doesn't know.
You know that he's going to die,
but you don't know how and why he's
going to die.
And so,
um,
and they don't know who did it,
who killed him and so forth.
And so there's lots of hooky questions
and curiosity,
but it's also a bit of a dramatic irony.
That's amazing.
I mean,
they,
when you see it,
you wonder why hasn't this been done
before?
Right.
And so in terms of executing stories,
I would say that it's,
um,
that the techniques are better than,
than ever in terms of the content of the
stories.
That's another question.
And in terms of what these stories are
about,
what they,
the depth to which they,
they bring their characters.
Uh,
I would say no,
we're where it's the stories are more
shallow overall.
That's a huge generalization.
But,
and postmodernism itself,
by definition mean shadowing us.
It means a satire of the techniques or
writing okay.
Calling attention to the techniques of
writing.
And that of course divorces you from the
content by the very nature of it.
And so in this post postmodern world,
wherever we are now,
um,
I would say that as a,
as a grand generalization,
that the content of stories are not the
quality that they were in the 50 golden
years from the 1920s to the 1970s on
stage page and screen everywhere in the
world,
especially the English speaking world,
the films,
the plays and the novels of that period
were magnificent in content.
And so we've learned to be more clever,
more experimental.
And I'm more skilled often in the
telling of stories today,
but I can't say that the content is what
they used to be.
I never lose faith in story.
Film may come and go as an art form and
be art forms have come and gone opera
more or less came and went and then just
gets revived endlessly.
There's very little cutting edge opera
today.
Um,
their,
their art forms that a rise up and
dominate a period of time in human
history and then receipt.
And so it film goes through that and
recedes.
So what,
because there will always be story and
um,
and the,
the,
the medium of the future I think is
television,
but certainly the novel and the theater
is still,
um,
uh,
alive and well for the most part,
despite some pretty mediocre
storytelling.
And so,
um,
the,
the art of storytelling,
the artist's story I never worry about.
People will always tell stories and they
will tell really great stories,
beautiful stories,
but the medium
of the future,
the medium that writers choose to,
to do what is the best work in the
future that changes human beings.
A great critic,
once Kenneth Burke said it,
stories are equipment for living.
Human beings need storytelling in order
to make sense out of life in order to
live as well and civilized as a human
being can.
And so they,
they will go to the storyteller,
uh,
for meaningful emotional experiences
that they can I get from life.
And then it just,
it just a matter of of which medium the
storytellers of the future choose to,
to dominate that period in time.
And then that's two will change in time.
The time that people spend in stories
created for them by a storytelling
artists today compared to 50 a hundred
years ago.
I mean it's,
it's triple or quadruple what it used to
be.
Um,
do they need it more?
Maybe you could make an argument that
the disintegration and relativization of
values in contemporary society,
society is so blurring that people
desperately need stories to help them
make sense out of life.
Because what we used to agree upon,
nobody agrees on anymore.
Society is,
you know,
this is obvious,
but it's so,
it's so splintered and so split.
And I mean,
there's a spectrum.
[inaudible] excuse me.
There's a spectrum that runs from,
uh,
I am my brother's keeper to every man
for himself and that on that we call
that liberals and then the right
conservatives.
And,
um,
this argument over are we are our
brother's keeper or is it every man for
themself is never been more ugly
and,
and fragmenting of,
of society.
And so people are clustering now in,
in,
depending upon their position on that,
on that spectrum of caring or not
caring,
um,
in such ways that they cannot even talk
to people who are anywhere else on that
spectrum.
And as a result,
uh,
there's more chaos in daily life and
then throw in a,
a,
a the great recession and a few other
chaos is like wars and,
uh,
people are desperate and they need
story.
Yeah.
I think you could make an argument now,
are they getting the quality of stories
a comic or tragic that would help them
live through this,
this really ugly period in history?
Probably not.
Uh,
but the writers do their best because
the writers are just citizens too,
you know,
and they're,
they're,
they've got no necessarily more
philosophical or psychological insight
into this than,
um,
than anybody else.
And so they,
the writer has to be a philosopher of a
kind today that they've never had to be
before.
They have to make sense out of a kind of
chaos.
The no one ever confronted before.
I mean,
the worst thing that in,
you know,
a hundred years ago or,
and the worst thing that could happen is
you die.
[inaudible] so people told stories about
how to live well or live meaningfully if
you could,
or the or tragedy,
one of the,
you know,
but,
but death was the worst thing.
Well,
there's far worse things now,
far worse things and,
um,
and people are literally
living health.
Could they,
they'd be better off dead all around the
world.
The suffering and the third world today
is of an extreme that the third world
has never suffered before.
Because generally speaking,
in the Third World,
people didn't starve to death.
They could farm.
But even that in many ways has been
lost.
Um,
I,
you know,
for a lot of reasons,
but yeah.
Okay.
The world is,
um,
is a,
in a worse state than I,
I,
that I know from history that people
would probably say,
well,
the black plague was,
um,
but I don't think so.
She,
because people understood the plague,
you get sick and you die.
Who can understand the banking system,
who can understand love,
who can understand?
Um,
uh,
parenting.
Yeah.
I mean,
these things that people thought they
knew,
they don't know anymore.
And so the,
the plague at least was clear.
It's terrible.
But it was clear.
The problem for people today is
confusion.
Uh,
in a world that should make sense and
wanting what you have more communication
than ever makes it less and less sense
than ever.
And so you need storytellers to make
sense out of that chaos.
But it says that it's a chaos of a very
different kind today.
And,
um,
the writers struggles.
Yeah.